herika one of the things that always say
that the future is fiction it's a story
that each one of us get to write every
day as we move forward into the into the
future that we collectively are are
making as of I vision for tomorrow for
the rest of us for myself specifically
is to do all that I can to help that
story which we are writing to be a good
story a cognizant story of story which
is empowering and enabling for all of us
here in Davos is quite amazing to see
the top of that pyramid you think about
the world the state of the world where
things are heading and sometimes about
the story which they're trying to write
it is my hope that all of us believe
that we have a role large and small in
writing our story and we want that story
to be a positive equitable one so each
one of us think about what is normal not
just for us but normal for others
because there is no such thing as a
constant normal nor is there such a
thing as a normal to which we should all
want or try to achieve that's it for now
all the best buy